okay so I'd like to begin by taking you
back to a time when Obama was first
inaugurated Edward Snowden had just fled
the
country and shiny was still in its
infancy uh the year was
2003 and at the time folks were
absolutely thrilled to be creating
reactive web applications in R and
thrilled that it looked like
this turns out 10 more than 10 years
later you can run that exact same code
with the latest shiny and get basically
the same
result there's not a lot of R packages
out there that can claim something like
this that you can take the same code
that you learned and wrote 10 years ago
and run it today and you get the same
result
but let me step back and ask is this a
feature or is it a
bug right it it's maybe somewhere in
between in the sense that this is really
great if you value value
reproducibility and stability that you
can have a certain level of confidence
that the code that you're writing today
or the code you wrote 10 years ago we're
going to put in a lot of effort to make
sure that that code is going to work in
the future that you can deploy the same
application and count on that still
working but on the other hand for
someone just getting started with shiny
today in
2023 this is not a delightful
experience uh unfortunately a lot of
people are still encountering this same
sort of hello world code that was
designed and created for a world in
2013 and uh it's just something that we
haven't put on the top of our priority
list for kind of bringing this uh first
getting started experience into the next
generation of shiny
UI and also to be fair it's not
necessarily fair to zero in on the Hello
World experience of shiny because really
the thing that makes shiny so awesome
and makes it stand out uh from maybe
other competitors is the really awesome
set of like the really rich ecosystem of
extensions that all of you have built
around
shiny uh but the thing about this
extension ecosystem and shiny itself is
it turns out that a lot of these tools
end up leaning on this U uh popular UI
framework called bootstrap and they tend
to lean on this UI framework to uh take
care of some of the uh details behind
styling and design decisions and in some
cases functionality for some of these UI
components and if you didn't know even
things like technically outside of the
shiny ecosystem like maybe our mark down
or quto or package down or book down
these projects as well you know chances
are if you're creating a website uh
through an r package chances are it's
probably using bootstrap at some level
to provide styling um and
functionality
and unfortunately if shiny were just to
upgrade bootstrap by default we would
force a lot of people into doing a lot
of work to update their projects so that
they're not left in a broken state so
and even if you know you uh you're not a
um maintainer of one of these projects
even if you've just created a
sophisticated shiny application and
you've written some JavaScript or css if
we were to upgrade bootstrap that would
potentially break some of the code that
you've written and cause you a lot of
work to
update now one good example of this is
shiny dashboard which not only depends
on bootstrap but also depends on
additional uh dashboarding
dependencies that also build on
bootstrap and haven't done really a
great job in recent years of keeping up
to date with bootstrap and um you know
making sure that they're not making
breaking changes to things that would
break update to shiny dashboard for
example So lately we've been working
towards making building out a framework
in BS lib uh building out a framework
that can kind of replace shiny dashboard
and improve upon it and making that
available through the BS lib r
package and even if you haven't already
heard of BS lib chances are you're
you've already used it uh because it's
now a dependency of shiny and our
markdown as and has kind of become a
centralized home for bootstrap assets
and logic that we've written that builds
on top of bootstrap it's kind of like a
central repository for these things to
live and be shared across
projects and you may have already used
BS lib more directly to upgrade your
project to a a modern version of
bootstrap which among other things gives
you access to really rich powerful
theming tools
but more recently we've been broadening
the scope of how we think about bs lib
to include a library of UI components
that are primarily focused on
dashboarding uh but we also are creating
these with uh um in mind that you might
want to be able to use these components
not only in a dashboard but maybe in a
quto document or a markdown or some
other um non-shiny
context
so that said with these components you
can make a great looking shiny dashboard
like this
one and these components should feel
familiar both in terms of how you
express them and how you interact with
them but are going to look a lot more
modern and better by default but also
allow you to go much deeper with styling
and their
functionality so let me give you a
highle overview of how I created this
dashboard first of all the top here I
have a nav bar at the very top of the
page where I have a a title and a logo
on the left hand side but on the right
hand side I have some navigation links
that allow me to navigate to different
pages in this dashboard and we're just
going to focus basically on this first
page of this dashboard for this talk but
to initialize this UI I can use this
page nabar function from BS lib and give
it multiple page definitions to get this
top level NAB bar with navigation to the
different
pages and Page n navbar comes with a
sidebar argument where I can just start
supplying UI elements to this this
sidebar and I get this nice page level
sidebar that's left aligned with the
main content
area and in my case here for this
dashboard I have a lot of controls so
I'm going to group them together with an
accordion component and this accordion
component can be used outside of a
sidebar it can be used inside of a side
sidebar and we have special awareness of
that situation to make it look nice and
uh render flush in the
sidebar um but this is going to help me
uh keep visual proximity amongst related
controls and also help users kind of
scan you know sets of related controls
in a way that's a lot better than just
dumping you know dozens of input
controls in a sidebar but give it some
nice organization and uh allow you to
scan a little bit better so here here by
default I'm showing you uh showing you
basically input controls for searching
for a flight path or flight
carriers but we could also be searching
by you know controls related to flight
time and
weather so let me go ahead and open up
this section uh called flight time which
has some input controls inside of it and
then this gives me some histograms uh
histogram sliders that allow me to uh
filter by uh departure time and arrival
time all right so moving on to the main
content area of this dashboard in this
first row I have three different value
boxes uh on the the that's showing me
the total number of flights and the
average departure delay and the average
arrival
delay and here to lay out these value
boxes in this single row with basically
like three different columns I can give
this to these value boxes to this layout
columns mechanism which will by default
kind of guess that I want to place all
three of these in one row in three
different columns with their widths
divided equally but of course you can go
a lot deeper with this with doing like
non-equal width columns and even
different widths at different break
points of Dei device
size and here also I've just put icons
into these value boxes but as we'll see
later we can also kind of customize what
we put into this showcase area is what
we call
it all right in the next row I have two
cards on the left here I'm displaying
flight paths and on the right hand side
I'm showing the average delay by
carrier again I'm going to use layout
columns to give me this kind of equal
with column uh
layout and then uh Supply it two
different cards uh with plotly outputs
um so plotly is providing the
visualization itself but the layout for
the cards and the cards themselves are
provided via the BS lib
package all right and it as it turns out
any card can gain the ability to expand
to a full screen view by setting this
full screen equal to true it allows a
user to come in and when they hover on
this card they'll see a little icon to
expand this card to a full screen view
so let's go ahead and expand this card
to full screen and this gives me a b
much better closer look at these flight
paths the interactive version I could
like further zoom in on this globe and
turn it around and stuff like that uh
but I want to focus on the BS lib aspect
of this and notice I have a title here
at the top of the card and right aligned
next to that I have this informational
icon that somebody could come in and
hover on this icon and get more
information about what's inside this
visualization and to implement this I'm
using BS Libs tool tip which is a pretty
General utility that allows you to
attach a tool tip to any UI element on
any
page uh but here I'm using it to attach
a tool tip uh to an icon which in most
cases you should probably be attaching
tool tips to icons uh and then also
placing it inside of the card
header
all right so let's go back to our
dashboard and let's zero in on the
average delay by
carrier so I have a pretty similar setup
here in terms of the BS lib components
where I have a card and a card title I
also have an icon here up right aligned
in the card
header uh but this icon instead of a
tool tip being attached to it I'm going
to attach a
popover which conceptually popovers are
quite similar to Tool tips uh but are
going to allow you to actually interact
with the stuff that goes inside of the
tool
tip so if a user came in and clicked on
this icon they're going to get a popover
that looks like this and for this
situation I've decided to put in a
couple input controls that allow me to
kind of tweak um parameters behind this
particular
visualization so in this case I've uh
put like a select input for people to
customize what category that I'm going
to average over to look at the average
delay so I could switch from carrier to
month and now I get this bar chart by
month instead of by carrier and gives me
a better idea of what time of the year
to be um to be
flying all right so let's go back to the
dashboard and now let's zero in on the
card on the bottom
all right this is going to give me a
better look and a closer look at the
distribution of delay times which is
right
skewed but I I want to focus in on again
kind of the upper right hand portion of
this card and uh highlight the fact that
I actually have navigation links here
similar to how the navigation looks
navigation looks at the very top of the
page so you're going to create this in a
pretty similar fashion to how you would
create the page level navigation but
this allows you to basically construct
different views for your card using
navigation Links at the
top so if if you look at the interactive
version of this uh you'll get a
different view of delay times over time
but for sake of this presentation I'm
going to skip over that view and I'm
going to highlight this other uh icon in
the upper right hand portion of this
card which uh indicates that we have a
right positioned sidebar that's closed
by default so and this is going to give
me kind of a nice alternative to
popovers uh where I can use it in a
similar way where I can provide
essentially like a drawer of additional
input controls that are particular to
this visualization that allow me to
customize again sort of parameters that
are specific to what's inside of this
card so it kind of provides like a nice
way for to scope your controls to sub
regions of the page versus having just
everything dumped into a page level
sidebar um so in this case I could um
choose to split up this distribution by
weekday and then this isn't going to
tell me a whole lot but it kind of just
shows a pretty uh stacked histogram
where this uh distribution is now broken
up by the day of the
week all right so again going back to
for our dashboard there's one last
component that I'd like to highlight
here uh which is this input dark mode
which essentially gives the user ability
to toggle dark mode in the
dashboard um so let me put that back
inside of the NAB bar this is kind of
like a standalone component that you
could put anywhere in the page but
probably just put it inside of the NAB
bar at the top it's where people would
expect it to be and when you click uh on
this toggle then um that will
essentially change bootstrap styling
defaults to be based on dark mode
instead of light
mode so this is a really nice option for
putting some of the theming control in
the hands of the user but also remember
with BS lib that we have a ton of
control over styling defaults uh
available to us like inside of our R
code so say I wanted to like change up
the primary color bring in a slightly
different font and maybe bring in like
some different background colors for the
value boxes I could um with a fairly
small amount of code update all of those
things to have a look like
this and a fair amount of that heavy
lifting is going to be done through the
BS BS theme function uh from BS lib
which uh gives you access to like
hundreds of different
um styling or theming defaults provided
by
bootstrap um so I can do a lot just by
setting the primary color to a purple
bring in some uh Google fonts uh using
this well this font Google does a lot of
work for you in terms of like
automatically importing font files
downloading them if you if need be and
actually caching them for future
runs um so there's a lot you can do with
like customizing main colors and fonts
with this BS theme one thing you need to
remember is to give this theme object to
the page
Constructor all right and now for a
component like value box we actually
give you kind of theming options that
are specific to that
component um which allows you to like
you know maybe have one value box that
start a little bit differently from
another value box but in this case I'm
using this uh gradient background
feature to make all three of these value
boxes have like this nice gradient
background another nice thing about
working in BS lib that you might uh not
notice right away is uh the fact that by
default you're not going to have this
awkward empty space at the bottom of
your main content
region um and this is because BS lib
gives you a filling layout by default
meeting that on larger displays outputs
will kind of grow to take up any
available space uh in in the window and
then as you make the window smaller
those outputs will shrink to basically
even evenly divide up the available
space like this but of course it also
gives you options for opting out of this
filling layout feature if you need
to right so if you'd like to play with
the interactive version of this app feel
free to uh screenshot this QR code it
give you a link to this bit.
lebs libf
flights um if you want you can search
for your flight home this this app has
it's these are all flights leaving from
Chicago in 2022 should give you an idea
of what kind of delay you should be
expecting um and also if you if you view
it on your phone it'll give you a good
sense of how these layouts work pretty
well and intelligently on mobile devices
as well
but maybe I'll don't visit it at once
because
maybe all right so to bring everything
together this is just a screen recording
of me kind of searching for different
flight paths I have 30 seconds left um I
want to step back for just a second and
mention there's kind of three common
themes that uh work well in information
Rich applications if you keep in mind
overview first like don't overwhelm your
user give them something high level and
useful to take away then give them tools
for zooming and filtering drilling down
into stuff they're interested in and
then getting details on demand through
tool tips and popovers I like this kind
of example that kind of does all three
at once where I have a bunch of value
boxes with a spark line inside of them I
can make it full screen and get details
thank you very
[Applause]
much